morning everyone I'd like to welcome you
to this very important day for us in the
school computer science and for Carnegie
Mellon overall to announce this major
new partnership that we're forming with
Yahoo research Yahoo he's been a strong
supporter of Carnegie Mellon for many
years I just thinking of a few things
they provided access to a major
computing facility called m45 for us
starting in about two thousand eight
that let us start doing research on how
do you work with very large collections
of data and do the computing over that
large data and that access was
instrumental actually for a number of
projects including a lot of the core
work that's going to be the basis of
this future work we're describing
they've also given machines for us to
use as server facilities both in SCS and
in behind school to do data analysis of
different types they've been very
generous with funding of graduate
fellowships we have a ping-pong table
it's purple and overall funding many
student activities and we're very
grateful for that but today what we're
talking about is a much bigger step both
in terms of a dollar amount but also in
many ways more significantly in terms of
what kind of connection we're forming
with Yahoo and what kind of partnership
were forming and that's what we're
really going to talk about today but and
so I'd like to now introduce president
of Carnegie Mellon subra Suresh to give
some remarks on his perspective on this
as well
Thank You Randy welcome and thank you
all for coming this morning it's my
pleasure to let you know if most of you
know already that Yahoo is committing 10
million dollars to a joint research
project with CMU faculty and students in
the School of Computer Science in the
department's of machine learning and
human-computer interactions so this
funding will support an exciting new
research project which our colleagues
have called project in mind which will
be the next or next to next next to next
generation of a personal agent that will
guide us in our day-to-day lives through
a variety of devices portable devices in
discovery learning and navigating
through our day-to-day lives this is an
unprecedented level of support for Yahoo
for a research project of this kind and
we are really delighted that yahoo has
chosen Carnegie Mellon as a partner to
make this happen and I can say that this
can only happen with a company that's as
innovative as Yahoo in its outreach to
the scientific community and to a
university as broad and as deep and as
innovative as Carnegie Mellon so it's
really a perfect match top scientists
faculty students from CMU top scientists
and engineers from Yahoo Yahoo labs are
embarking on a mission a unique
partnership involving major investments
of time money real-time data
intellectual resources and two-way
intellectual traffic between Pittsburgh
and Silicon Valley and we know in the
wintertime which way it's going to go
but at other times it may go in a
different direction and if you see some
of our faculty and students and some of
her yahoo colleagues running around
campus with strange devices and strange
behavior you know why why that's
happening in the future I had the
pressure of talking to yahoo CEO marissa
meyer just a few weeks ago at the World
Economic Forum in Davos and in the brief
conversation that she and I had it was
abundantly clear to me how excited she
was about this project and I also had
the opportunity to meet with several
members of the senior leadership team at
Yahoo I can also say a few other things
from the different vantage points I from
which I have looked at these kinds of
interactions in earlier in the press
release Tom Mitchell pointed out that
when you go to a typical funding source
for a faculty member or a student you go
to a federal agency to get support such
as a National Science Foundation
typically it's a finite amount of money
for one or two students in a typical
project unless it's a major center for a
relatively short period of time three
years and that provides you an
opportunity to do scientific research in
a certain way but may not give you the
bandwidth either in terms of resources
or into in terms of opportunities to
explore real-time data in a major way
and one of the remarkable things about
this from my previous vantage point as
the director of the National Science
Foundation is that embedded in all of
this is deep rigorous highly scholarly
scientific and engineering research and
that research combined with industrial
relevance industrial applications and
human behavior can change global society
ways and that's what this partnership is
all about so Yahoo is a cool company and
we may have cool portable devices at our
disposal that's fine underlying all of
this is scholarship let's not forget
that and this is a very very good
example of how intellectually powered
deep rigorous scholarly work changes the
world the last thing I want to say is
that the combination of skill and
imagination that exists at the school of
computer science and across Carnegie
Mellon will be a foundation for superb
partnership in this discovery and this
journey over the next few years
personally I'm really looking forward to
seeing what exciting science engineering
products and lifestyles will emerge out
of this partnership and I'm really proud
of all my colleagues and and students at
CMU I'm also extremely grateful to our
friends and partners in this colleagues
from yahoo i would like to also thank
Ron Brockman chief of Yahoo labs and Don
McCullin one of our own alums was
involved in corporate relations at Yahoo
for all their hard work and also Beverly
for her efforts and many of the
colleagues from yahoo who have joined us
this morning thank you very much
good morning I'm Ron Brockman from yahoo
great pleasure to be here today thank
you president Suresh Thank You Randy and
I loved what you just said because not
everyone knows it but the idea of
rigorous scholarship sort of deep
scientific thinking applied to very
pragmatic and important problems that
people care about is really what yahoo
labs is about and so that makes this
partnership just absolutely ideal so
what I wanted to do this morning is very
briefly and it will have to be brief
give you a quick overview of Yahoo labs
for those of you who are not familiar
with us I guess I'll have to and forth
your apologies it's kind of interesting
many of you are familiar with Yahoo many
of you use our services by quite a few
years ago when the idea of bringing a
research capability into a very young
internet company was raised at first
there was a lot of skepticism the the
pace at which innovation happened in the
company was extremely fast not necessary
a lot of rigor went into experimentation
and and deployment of services and
products and when you look at sort of
equations like you see in front of you
people would scratch their head and say
how could that possibly be relevant but
a lot of things have changed over the
last 10 years or so and now I think the
view is shared across the entire senior
management of the company and and
probably throughout the entire company
that research of the sort that you all
do and are intimately familiar with is
absolutely fundamental to the success
and and certainly the future of the
company and with that a number of years
ago we started to build up a research
capability focusing on the areas which
made the most sense for the company at
the time and those capabilities have
expanded over time and as did our
outreach to universities that allowed us
to eventually conceive of and start to
execute projects like this the labs
itself has more than 200 people now
we're
wyd I'll show you a quick map in a
moment of where we are we hire mainly
what we call scientist which are always
a PhD level graduates in many different
fields which we'll talk about in a
moment and we have also a very strong
class of engineers that work in an
experimental mode that we happen to call
research engineers we do in some cases
very fundamental exploration of
computational and economic phenomena
computational is obvious but when you do
things like deal with very large numbers
of advertisers large numbers of places
advertisements can appear and many many
many many customers using your services
the combinatorics and the notion of
markets come into play very
significantly from the original sort of
simple-minded view of auctions for
keywords on search pages to a wide
variety of bidding mechanisms for
complex campaigns economics is the heart
of a lot of what we do certainly in our
advertising business another thing that
we do typical role for a corporate
research lab is we try to anticipate
technology changes scientific
developments that are created in the
world around us and look for
opportunities for the company even if we
don't invent them ourselves so one of
the reasons it's wonderful to have very
strong relationships with the academic
community and to participate in
international conferences and
publications is that you get to share
both ways both what you're doing and
what other people are doing and that's
very critical it's it's Silicon Valley
thinks very highly of itself in many
ways and a lot of it's sort of an
inward-looking self-sustaining ecosystem
the fact of the matter is we all know
not everything of Merit is invented in
California so it's very important that
we keep our eyes and ears open it work
very closely with the very innovative
people who exist everywhere outside of
not not only in California but elsewhere
the other thing that we care about
because we're a very large
consumer-facing company as you know if
you include
the tumblr acquisition we have over 1
billion customers it's pretty large
number I don't know the total amount of
data that we have but its its large it's
certainly in the in the petabytes
multiple petabytes range but what makes
or breaks companies like ours and and
what can help people best is is sort of
very largely determined by societal
processes and so we very much need to
understand both how individual users
interact with technology and therefore
there's great interest in the
human-computer interaction Institute
here as well as well as larger
demographic things that happen and we've
now all seen the rise of computational
social media and they seem to have a
very profound effect on on the way
people consume services and communicate
with on and one another and share
information so again we can't just sit
in our offices and invent stuff we need
to understand what's going on the world
at large so we play multiple roles in
our labs on behalf of the entire company
and our customers now with respect to
the kind of work we do sometimes people
think that industrial labs tend to be
totally applied very near tome focused
and barely doing what we would all think
of a science and we certainly do some of
that that's of necessity because if some
urgent needs to get innovative things
deployed but we really cover the full
spectrum of work from a basic research
to very applied work I like to think in
terms of that term that came from Donald
Stokes book called Pasteur's quadrant I
don't know if you're familiar with it
where there are different types of basic
research and it seems most appropriate
and industrial setting to do something
you might call use inspired basic
research very fundamental you have no
prediction on whether your
experimentation will succeed you're
dealing with very challenging
computational mathematical and physical
phenomena but nevertheless you always
have in the back of your mind what the
world would look like if you succeeded
and how it might change things in
people's lives so you kind of use
potential use as an inspiration for the
focus of your work
although of course we can never predict
how ultimately our technology will
affect the world the nuna case we do we
do fundamental research we do a lot of
publishing we're very proud of our best
paper awards and fellow awards and
chairmanships of various conferences and
organizations in that regard if you
visited us you'll see we feel in many
respects like a university setting but
we also have very very significant
connections to our software development
teams we call them engineering at Yahoo
and our product folks so that we can
help them succeed and also really
interesting ideas that we come up with
actually make their way into products
and in some cases very very rapidly and
a happy later to talk about examples of
that the mission I've just sort of
implied the mission over all of the
organization basically we are the
forward-looking thinkers in the company
we provide deep technical expertise in a
wider range of critical subjects to
product and engineering folks and
corporate management and strategy and we
are we try to be the incubator for a
pretty significant scientific
experimentation that will ultimately
lead towards more inspiring and more
delightful products for our users to to
take advantage of the labs was
established in 2005 we started out as a
core research organization we eventually
expanded to include more of what we call
applied science and I have to say like
many organizations we've had our ups and
downs you know the economic sort of
structure that surrounds us but
nevertheless we have had undeniably
critically an incredibly strong support
from our corporate management from the
very day we established the organization
in 2005 it's been kind of staggering
I've worked in other places like 80 and
the federal government we don't have go
no-go conditions we we don't have to
write proposals to do our work each year
and by the way in case you're wondering
nor do you in collaborating with us no
go no go conditions and in fact we we
have a very simple funding mechanism
which is direct funding support from the
very top and for any of you who have
lived in other corporate worlds with
different models that's an incredible
place to get started so we have been
thrilled with that level of support
continuously you're all familiar with
our relatively new CEO Marissa Meyer
actually often identifies herself as an
AI person she's happy to get down in the
trenches and talk machine learning math
with you which is absolutely fantastic
for us and she's a very very strong
supporter and this collaboration
certainly would not have been possible
without her direct support I mention we
have more than 200 scientists I won't go
over the disciplines that we have that
we're working on but they're basically
the things that are obvious and in some
cases a little subtle that really matter
to a company with the kind of products
and audience that we have we are in a
number of places around the world our
largest location is in sunnyvale which
is corporate headquarters we also have a
few people in Southern California we
have a growing team in New York that
happens to be where my office is and
maybe a little bit easier for you all to
get to than in sunnyvale but not more
attractive in the winter I can tell you
that we have a small location that's
working in concert with the University
in Chile in Santiago a very small but
growing group in London yahoo has a
growing presence there a fairly sizable
research lab in Barcelona which I would
highly recommend that all of you visit
especially if you like to eat great
place it's a great place for innovation
the city there is really driving mobile
services the international mobile
Congress is there every year it's a
great place to bring together people
from all over Europe to do really
exciting research we also have a very
strong and growing team in Haifa in
Israel absolutely superb computer
scientists there many of them with a
very entrepreneurial bent we have a
group in bangalore which is another very
large labs excuse me yahoo location and
we also have a team in Beijing in China
now the group's we have in these various
places are outlined here again I will
go over them we try to keep we try to
avoid duplication between locations
there's some cases where you need
expertise in the same field in multiple
places and we certainly try to be
opportunistic so we didn't pick a set of
topics in advance and say X will be done
in Barcelona and y and Haifa and build
to that we looked for the talent that
was available and collaboration
opportunities within the business that
were local and it was sort of an organic
growth but we keep an eye on it and we
manage it all very centrally we have a
small senior leadership team of the labs
200 people is a nice number it will get
bigger but it's not too large to manage
so we are all very closely in touch and
we have multiple meetings in California
every year we're almost everybody comes
together so it really feels like a very
very tight-knit scientific family
worldwide we put together a quick word
cloud of the words that were mentioned
when people described all of the the
names and subject matter of the team
efforts amongst our labs teams you can
take a quick glance at it I don't think
this was cooked tom I don't know but um
machine learning and data mining
certainly stand out very prominently I
think that's real action there's a very
very large emphasis and the company now
in machine learning and you can see lots
of other subjects that are again we all
know and love them and are extremely
good matches to Carnegie Mellon now I
don't want to spend a lot of time go
every detail because i'd like to have
Tom and Justine come up and talk to you
much more about what we're going to be
doing together so let me just run
through a few areas really quickly a lot
more words on the slides then I will say
forgive me for that but just to give you
a hint of some of the really key focus
areas in the labs we have for this year
this is not an exclusive list so if you
don't see your favorite subject up here
doesn't mean we don't care about it but
these are amongst the most prominent
ones now with our current very large set
of consumer facing services and the
needs of our advertisers we like to
think of ourselves as primarily now what
you might call a personal
company I think the secret to success
and the space that we're in the future
is not just harnessing information and
news and sports and celebrities and
fantasy sports and things which which
are very important but getting them to
people in a way that they really
personally each appreciate and all of us
is different so doing personalization at
the scale of hundreds of millions of
users that's machine learning at scale
if I've ever seen it and we look at that
both in the content world and in
advertising and if you look at the yahoo
homepage or many of our other key sites
like yahoo news sports finance etc there
are already personalized streams of
content facing you that could be very
different for you than the person
sitting next to you the bottom of the
page you can scroll and scroll and
scroll and those articles are ranked by
what we believe will be the relevance
and interest to you and we're always
looking for ways for you to confirm or
deny that so we can be learning
constantly so real time learning at
absolutely massive scale is is first and
foremost on our radar so to speak as a
personalization company and there are
lots of other examples if you're
familiar with Yahoo Answers their ways
of getting high quality answerers to
answer questions for you referrals from
queries that involve a certain amount of
learning we've got some time series
anomaly detection that we use in
determining what stocks might be
trending for our finance pages we're
working on some really innovative ways
to use social information among other
things in recommending photos on our
flickr community service which has i
don't know how many photos we have is
billions and billions right nine billion
photos that's a lot for you to sort of
thumb through if you're looking for
something interesting so you're going to
depend on lots of machine help and we've
got some really innovative things that
are in the pipeline there you may have
heard if you listen to any of marissa
meyer speeches that mobile is really top
of the list for us as a company
and we're attacking that in the labs in
multiple ways we're looking at platforms
sort of distributed computing alerting
platforms that are going to be
significant because people move from one
device to another many many times during
the day we're also trying to anticipate
brand new form factors for mobile
computing and mobile services and that's
another place where we're really looking
forward to working with you we may not
in fact build any hardware ourselves but
we need to take a pretty good guess at
what's coming so when it arrives we're
right there ready with personalized
adapted services that fit ideally in the
environment in which these new mobile
technologies are being used um we do I
mentioned earlier we do basic research
we have a pretty significant growing
effort largely in New York but not only
in in core computer science we're hiring
optimization people algorithms people
people who really know computational
complexity very deeply people who are
infinitely better at proving theorems
than I am and we are partnering them up
with lots of applied people and
including our engineering folks because
some of the challenges that we have
given the scale of data and the stuff
that we have to move around and the
networking constraint and the like just
needs very very deep computational
insights to address we also have
advertising as a critical ingredient of
the company that's how we in fact make
most of our money and there's lots of
elements to what you might call
advertising science or computational
advertising I mentioned markets before
matching users and ads is pretty
critical timeliness running campaigns
effectiveness of ads fighting ad spam on
behalf of our users really quite
critical and I mentioned the infinite
stream now we're offering ads integrated
in that stream and they better be things
that you like and they better be
relevant and they better fit or people
are going to stop reading our content so
very very important element there we're
doing a lot of interesting work in video
and I just mentioned flicker so image
process
is incredibly important to us don't have
time to go into details but we can talk
offline there's lots and lots of work we
need to do in all aspects of dealing
with different multimedia content and I
mentioned this before let me add one
more time one of our groups in New York
is actually called scalable machine
learning research and one more time let
me emphasize we really mean scalable and
we're actually working on a platform so
that engineers who have absolutely no
background in machine learning they've
never heard of Bayes or decision trees
can actually easily hook up their data
sources and run appropriate machine
learning algorithms on them at humongous
scale and get results that they can use
in their work on an everyday basis so
this is really interesting research
experiment even though it's kind of an
engineering project because we want to
integrate absolutely state-of-the-art
and newly evolving learning methods in a
way though that novices can use every
day because as I've mentioned a couple
of times learning is used almost
everywhere in the company you name a
capability either internal or product
based and machine learning probably has
something to do with it so to wrap up
you're probably aware that we have many
different ways in which we reach out and
connect with the academic world we have
a program called web scope that's been
around for a long time where we share
anonymized data sets there's probably
close to 50 of those available now many
of them have used here at carnegie
mellon we have a program where we do
collaborative work with faculty called
the faculty research and engagement
program randy mentioned earlier today
about a server donation we made here we
have these incredibly large data centers
as you can imagine and the equipment
rotates pretty quickly and so we end up
with these almost brand new not quite
large numbers of servers that at one
point Don mcgillin sort of notice were
not go
anyway are useful and so we created this
program we could actually turn those
into gifts to universities so that
people could put them together they
could experiment with cluster computing
with clouds or just use them as sort of
raw scientific computing resources Randy
I think you said there were over 400
week for 32 shipped to Carnegie Mellon
but we've shipped to 2000 almost 3000
servers to how many universities
approaching 40 different universities
around the world and that was a really
wonderful insight that Dan Don had and
now where can we continue to spread
those around and of course we have a
very very active summer internship
program bringing people to all of our
labs locations for what we hope to be a
great summer experience you can watch us
on these various media channels and with
that I think Tom are you next or Scott
ok i'm going to introduce Scott Gaffney
who's one of the senior leaders of the
labs Scott is our most critical partner
with other parts of the business around
personalization and he'll spend a little
time telling you about what that means
in the Yahoo contacts so thank you very
much
excellent thank you Ron and thanks for
giving me this opportunity so what I try
to do is get a flavor of what
personalization at Yahoo is it's very
hard to do is a lot of depth to it I
don't want to get too technical but I
wanted to give a sense really what we
wanted to offer as part of this
relationship really i'm looking at you
two guys you know there's the key part
now i don't have much time i think i
have less than 15 minutes so we'll see
what happens so what is personalization
at Yahoo so it's a really three things
so understand what makes each user
different that's key that's personal
personalization represent these
differences a critical part how do we
write this down how do we send it
through the company and then how do we
get this into the product so as Ron
mentioned I play a strong partner to the
rest of the company in products and
really this is that this is one of the
most important pieces of the thing if
you can do the first two but you can't
do the third no one knows how this is it
a critical part so where do you see it
as another interesting thing that we
touch down a little bit earlier so you
see it on you know Yahoo properties so
you know the main this happens to be the
front page of yahoo you see it on
portals so we have a video portal so the
types of videos you see we do video
recommendation you see it on tumblr
right so now know tumblr and us or are
together so today even today we're doing
blog recommendation on tumblr you stated
mobile app so we purchased the company
recently you may not have heard about
called a v8 they essentially organized
they build personalized launchers as we
might call them that organize your apps
in a certain way and we have other
mobile applications this happens to be a
mobile version of kind of the video
portal that yahoo has which they call
screen and so there we do again video
recommendation so what you see is
there's many places that this goes and
there's many types of objects in many
contexts in which we have to do
personalization so again doing those
first three things is critical we have
to do the first two what makes you
different how to represent that and then
how do we distribute that to all these
products is is tricky so this is an
interesting slide so I kind of cooked
this together maybe about eight months
ago to get a sense of what is the scale
yahoo how does that compared to all the
other let's call them person
companies in the world it's kind of
interesting back in the hand scratchy so
don't get too upset if it's a little bit
off but Yahoo we easily have a billion
users so that's interesting we have
hundreds of billions of page views per
month easily it's just page views we got
lots of other things are going on this
is this is not even including mobile for
example we have billions of items to
recommend which is quite interesting so
we have lots and lots of articles we
have many many videos we have lots and
lots of photos as we just said we have
answers as Ron mentioned we got updates
we got tumble updates we got lots of
thing actually we're getting millions of
new things every single day which is
incredible actually so if we compare
that to some other things i pulled out
netflix has 30 million people not that
many quite quite less they have less
than 200 thousand things they're going
to recommend and they only get a hundred
new every day it doesn't seem to be at
the quite scale of what we're doing with
but what's interesting to me when I
start digging into these numbers pandora
has 20 to 80 million listeners just
about 200,000 songs hunters new similar
the scale is quite different if you look
at Amazon even Amazon's interesting has
200 million accounts there's 50 million
things and you get thousands new every
day again this is back in the hand
scratch I think these are reasonably
close maybe not perfect and it's not
till you get to youtube that you get
someone who's in the same scale so
YouTube I definitely got billions of
users I got tens of billions of things
going on and I'm getting at least
500,000 new every single day summer
second summer an hour so you have to
really there's not many people to
compare the scale of Yahoo to which is
interesting one of them I think the main
thing why this is interesting is that if
you want to do personalization and you
have you know 30 million users that's
quite different than if you have a
billion hid everything changes it in
terms of how you represent the people
but how you deliver that to the product
like how you store this information how
do you push it to the product becomes
infinitely more difficult so challenge
is to do to scale so what does it mean
why is having a billion items tricky so
one of the tricky things is extracting
the same type of signal from all the
different types of content items I have
so extracting you know entities from
images is very tricky and very different
than extracting entities from say news
articles for example and likewise with
tweets so
automatically in predicting quality so
pretty clean quality of a tweet is very
different than predicting quality of an
article or video very tricky but you
have to do all this at the same time
otherwise you can't recommend all these
things together to duping you know say
images and news articles are very
different blending all these things
together becomes very tricky so it just
becomes having lots and lots and lots of
these types and having billions of them
becomes very tricky buildings and users
the biggest thing i think is space
optimization how do i store billion
things about you and then you know push
it around all these different products
very very expensive actually this is one
of the most expensive things that we do
in yahoo's actually store what we know
about users and actually make it
available real time to all the different
products it's a very expensive
proposition I often fight with the
engineers because I want to add a
thousand more things I know about you
and they say no you get ten so it
becomes very tricky which ten do I
choose so another another interesting
point which which may make some sense or
not is that when you have a billion
users you have hundreds of millions in
in different states so you have hundreds
of millions every day of new users
because people say clear their cookies
or they come with a different device or
people are buying new devices all the
time they might come to yahoo they might
not login and they're brand new and I
still want to personalize their
experience within a few say clicks or
taps so I had to deal with those people
every day plus the people who have been
logging in for years plus the people
just logged in for a month and coming up
with strategies to solve for a hundred
million users at a time becomes also
very tricky it's almost like a separate
company in each in each case modeling
issues one interesting thing we talked
about was last year we said well how do
you build a billion by billion
collaborative filtering matrix it
becomes insane even if you could build
it like how do you deploy how do you
move around it just comes very tricky
and again many of these problems no one
else has to deal with because they don't
have a billion by billion users so the
other this last point I think Tom very
much appreciates is while at the same
time on getting ten billions billions
and billions of new ratings every day
between all these billion objects so
it's not that I just built this thing
once I have to update it every second
essentially this becomes tricky and so
this is really the last thing which is
you start building a good product and
then Marissa comes and says hey I want
that updated you like every second now
so literally everything has to be online
everything has to be incremental you
can't do anything batch and you have to
do essentially everything very very
quickly so again it's another constraint
that makes the problem harder and also
limits kind of you know the technology
we have today how it can be useful so
literally all these things have massive
research projects that you know
literally we don't know how to solve all
these things in the best way today and
we don't have enough people who don't
have enough time to go figure this all
out so this is a critical piece
literally I believe of the relationship
and so again kind of getting to what is
that what is that Yahoo so we have kind
of a high level architecture where you
know one thing we do is understand
content all the types of content we
understand the users we have and there's
various segments of users so they talk
about new moans old ones and then we
have you know a ranking and serving
component you can call it that which is
kind of the recommendation engine itself
this is you know and there's you know
the users are pushing data to all these
systems and we're pushing data to them
in some way and you know this is very
high level in a sense that there may be
several of these depending on how you
want to push the stuff to users but in
general you're solving these three major
pieces so looking at Yahoo up to today
we have a long history of
personalization we focus on you know
people tell us things so we have
explicit personalization and Yahoo
you've been telling us stuff for a long
time we learn things about you so we
implicitly do this and then you push
this to content ads and we've been doing
this for many many years about more than
10 years ago we really literally
invented behavior targeting for
advertising and you know as many many
years before anyone else essentially
caught up so it's very long history but
in the past 18 months we've had a big
focus on that particularly because
Marissa is big on personalization so one
of the things that done is in 18 months
we've literally rebuilt the system four
times and so you build the system once
you put technology in gent you push
before and you learn what you need next
and so you just throw the old system
when you rebuild all over again right
I'm so rebuilding four times in 18
months is kind of a little bit a little
bit crazy and actually immerses a little
bit crazy
this is great we fit we fit well
together so it's sure we use some stuff
from pieces of them but literally weary
bleeped each time and each time you do
that you allow scale in another
dimension so it could be number and
types of items or different types of
profiles or or other types of things
learning type and speed is a critical
one so we want to be able to learn about
you literally real time you you tell us
something we learn right then and give
you something better than we would have
a minute before and essentially this is
a conversation so the CMU partnership I
just wrote a couple bullet points not
critical but literally personalized
experiences mobile apps people are
looking for information and they're
trying to get things done and what we
want to do is enable this new researcher
by levering this stuff leveraging this
stuff we've built so there's makes no
sense for seeing me to try to build for
architectures in 18 months we can do
that and and we can leverage that and do
fantastic research I think that's a
critical piece that's kind of the that's
kind of the high-level overview I don't
really want to go too much cuz I didn't
have much time but I had a couple more
slides that maybe I'll pass and at this
point I'll bring up Justine
thank you Scott I know that every time I
hear one of these talks from somebody at
the research labs I get more and more
excited and more and more convinced
about the similarity and approached the
overlap and interests and the wonderful
enthusiasm that both sides of this
partnership bring and that's very
exciting so it's nice to have people
throw money at us but I'd really
actually rather something where we share
passion and that's clearly the case here
and that's very exciting so we've been
talking about personalization and that's
a key word for yahoo right now first
there's also a keyword for lots of other
people in lots of other places and it's
interesting to me what is meant by
personalization in many places that
don't take this as seriously as Yahoo
does personalization is either trivial
or it's impossible so what's actually
meant by personalization what I'm going
to do in the next 15 minutes is talk
about places where our work is leading
to approaches that we're going to bring
in this partnership with Yahoo Beverly
Harrison one of the scientists at yahoo
has been doing some research into what
adults and teens think about
personalization they don't really
believe that personalization is going on
and they don't really understand how it
would go on and maybe that's not
surprising if this is the kind of
personalization we see so if i take what
Scott talked about really I want to
drill down into what's meant by learn
and what's meant by understand and this
is how we're thinking about things in
order to really personalize in an
interesting way you need to learn about
the world in such a way that you can
present that learning to the user you
need to learn about the user but that's
not enough you can't just stick sensors
into something and say wow I got all
this stuff you have to use that stuff to
make inference
is about the user infer underlying
psychological states for example or
beliefs and on the basis of those
inferences you can't just stop there
that has to be turned into and I think
that Scott's products ended up to
product you have to make that into a
compelling experience it's not enough to
say to the user you are sad next user
that has to be turned into something
interesting and those compelling
experiences stuck on a desktop or a
single device they have to be available
anywhere anytime so that that
personalization feels like one thing
across your experience with Yahoo so
I've just curated some work Tom and I
cherry picked some work across the
school of computer science and there are
lots of other examples but these are
some examples that we would like to
bring to the table that we'd like to
start out with when we work with you
guys so tom has been working for several
years now on Nell the neverending
language learner and Nell has been
working for four years on reading the
web and it has learned more than 70
million beliefs now what does that mean
that means something like what you see
up here the Maple Leafs play hockey you
might know that you might not know who
the Maple Leafs are I didn't but if it's
something you care about you don't want
to have to sit your recommender down and
say Maple Leafs a team a hockey team
hockey teams play hockey I want to know
more about hockey we don't have time for
that stuff so learning about the world
in order to present that work to you is
very important Nell has recently been
joined by Neil who is the neverending
image learner and Neil like Nell is
running 24 hours a day seven days a week
roughly July on a 200 core cluster so
this is work by evanov Gupta you can see
that in this work also Neal is learning
to extract information about the world
not just from text but from images and
as you heard from Ron this is a much
more difficult problem but neil has
already for example learn that wheels
are round and cars have wheels and those
are the kinds of things that are going
to help us recommend interesting stories
to somebody stories that are related to
previous stories but as I said it's not
enough to just gain facts you have to
make inferences about those facts and in
the same way that we need to make
inferences about facts about the user we
need to make inferences about facts
about the world this is worked by
William Cohen where he's learned how to
do inferences across huge knowledge
spaces such as now so really reasoning
at scale over millions and millions of
beliefs by using random walks across
that knowledge graph so for example if
you want to know what state Pittsburgh
is in one of the things that this system
has learned is to look for another city
that also might be in Pennsylvania and
thereby figure out that Pittsburgh is in
Pennsylvania or to look for a company
that might be in Pittsburgh and with
some confidence probably less than the
confidence of finding another city
thereby infer that that company is in
Pittsburgh and that Pittsburgh is in
Pennsylvania or in Tokyo with hopefully
less confidence so I talked about
learning about the world but it's also
important to learn about the user and
Scott talked on Scott and Ron both I
think talked about news as being one
important place where we have to
understand what users want to read one
of
reporters who was at the press
conference this morning came up to me
and said basically this sounds really
boring I mean it's only going to tell me
what I'm interested in this means my
life is going to be very dull and Emma
brunskill is working at forming models
of the user that can allow us to find
stories that appeal to the user already
but in places where there are
uncertainty in the learned model we can
present news stories that allow us to
understand whether something new is also
interesting to the user so this is one
way of understanding the user making
inferences about the user another way of
gathering data about the user is what an
in de call behavioral imaging so our
mobile devices have lots and lots of
sensors on them today there's a GPS
there's bluetooth there's a battery
there's Wi-Fi often an accelerometer a
barometer a magnetometer all kinds of
things all of which can collect
information about us and much the same
way as an x-ray might have done imaging
of a human in the past but as I said
it's not enough to simply collect those
facts about a user what can you do with
them and the nin has developed the aware
framework and this aware framework
allows him to do truly exciting and
important inferences from that
behavioral imaging for example he's
built GPS systems that can predict where
you're going and therefore proactively
route you around traffic rather than my
current GPS which I have to keep
pressing find alternate route until it
randomly finds one that works reminder
systems that can notice that there are
anomalies in a schedule and routine
events in a schedule and use both of
those to predict the best way to deal
both with your routine and with the
anomalies and so forth it can detect
multiple types of engagement it can
detect predictors of binge drinking it
can detect various symptoms of disease
so one of these systems uses behavioral
imaging
to predict which children are going to
be diagnosed with autism autism
diagnosis have been relatively late in a
child's life usually when a child goes
to school but by that time it's very
late to do an intervention if you can
predict from behavioral imaging who's
going to be diagnosed with autism you
can intervene much earlier and much more
effectively another way of gathering
data and inferring underlying
psychological states is in this work by
Jason Hong and John Zimmerman so we know
that returning soldiers have a high rate
of depression and a higher incidence of
PTSD than the general population and
they carry cell phones and cell phones
of course monitor not just the numbers
that we call but the patterns amongst
those numbers they also know where we
are and they know that when we're moving
and we can also with many devices for
example this one that I'm wearing detect
sleep patterns so Jason and John have
been able to show in preliminary results
that they can detect the likelihood of
depression and PTSD based on amount of
time spent at home so you can imagine
that somebody might go from home to the
supermarket to visit a friend and to
work if they stay at home all the time
or if they simply go from home to work
with no other social contact you might
imagine that something is wrong so a
combination of time at home disrupted
sleep communication volume is correlated
with self report on the ces-d scale and
that's very important work in today's
world work by dance Warrick similarly
uses behavioral sensing in this instance
to do something that seems quite out in
the future which is to detect the
emotion that the user of the system is
feeling so this is a coach that helps
people who've had strokes to regain the
use of their limbs but one thing that we
know about stroke victims is quite often
they may not have
the same amount of language as they did
earlier how do we know how far to push
them and if they're working with an
autonomous system without a therapist in
the room how do we know when we've gone
past what's helpful to them well this
particular system does emotion
recognition in furs emotions on the
basis of behaviors on the part of the
user and therefore knows when to stop
the coach and say would you like to
start again another day once again it's
sensing aspects of the user and using
those surface level behaviors to make
inferences about things that we cannot
see that is underlying psychological
states but of course it's those
psychological states that we want to act
upon and so those inferences are key I
talked about the work on anomalies and
routines and Jason and John did the
initial work on the sensing John and an
IND worked on turning that into a
compelling experience this is a system
called person place time view and if I'm
correct this may have arisen from a time
when one of the parents doing this
research left a child standing on a curb
because it was assumed that another
parent was doing the pickup well it
happens to all of us are are maybe not
that exact thing but the fear of that
certainly because our routines are so
complicated and because we're trying to
reconcile them with the very complicated
schedule of somebody else so this system
learns and displays plans that are often
undocumented in the family routine and
something like that can reduce your
anxiety around leaving a kid on a curb
allows you to plan a better life and as
such also allows people to feel like
they are being taken care of in the way
they want to be taken care of so it's
not that the system does something for
you it doesn't pick up your kid for you
it allows you to feel like a good parent
and picking up your child an interesting
twist on what I've been talking about in
terms of
sensing things about the user inferring
underlying states and providing
compelling experiences is work being
done by Jeff Bingham with a team of
others and what's interesting about this
is that rather than building an
autonomous agent or assistant to help
people with answers to particular tasks
he's built a system that can gather
together answers from the crowd in such
a way that those answers can be
transferred to the user in real time so
you can ask a question like I'm on
vacation in LA I was hoping to find a
good place for lunch tomorrow and
virtually instantly you can hear back
what part of LA are you in westward over
by UCLA I try pizza katoh and so on and
so forth this looks like a real
conversation because it is a real
conversation however what you need to
know is that there are hundreds of
people looking at this question
submitting answers and the system is
choosing the best answers and bringing
those together to make something that
looks like a single assistant giving you
aid what's just as exciting it as that
however is the fact that these data are
then sent back to us to use to train
natural language processing systems to
Train personalization systems so we
understand for example the kinds of
questions they're asked so that we can
be ready for them the kinds of answers
that we need to provide and how
information needs to be gathered in
order to provide those answers so this
is a kind of a loop that brings us to
better AI by initially using a crowd
finally I said that these compelling
experiences need to be available
anywhere and everywhere they need to
segue from our desktop to a variety of
mobile devices or tablets to the
dashboard of our car and that's going to
be what allows us to feel like we truly
have information at our disposal rather
than devices at our disposal we have the
knowledge that we need other kinds of
compelling experiences
are just on mobile devices but on our
own bodies and work by Chris Harrison
has shown that we can bring users closer
and closer to the computing power of
these personalization technologies by
actually displaying information on the
user's own body or on the world around
the user and new work by chris is in
fact developing a light bulb in this
instantiation the light bulb had wires
but in the most recent instantiation
this was work he's doing with Robert
Xiao this light bulb is wireless it just
screws into a socket and turns whatever
is beneath it into an interactive
computing surface so everywhere
persistent available personalized with a
much more deep version of
personalization these are the things
that we're really excited about pursuing
in this collaboration
so we have time for some Q&A all and
every questions or appropriate here yeah
and we'll bring up our speakers here too
much of this Yahoo the Greek and
buildings run the agreement is for five
years and you may have heard the tomah
building is about 10 billion dollars I
think this room or child yep that was
here
it's it's pretty simple so on our side
we have Don mcgillin dime I'm to stand
up and tell yourself Don is one of our
campus relationship managers in our
academic relations organization Don
lives here as randy said he's not only
an alum he's a former employee of the
University he's very local so he's our
main liaison person around anything
having to do with the partnership and
then we have on our side a series of
technical leads along several tracks
that are quite critical so there are
three or four people who on the Yahoo
side have agreed to kind of be the
primary contact a long lines of machine
learning let's say or HCI etc and on
your side go ahead tom for the faculty
who are interested in the question of
well how do we get engaged in this or
the students the answer to that is the
Justin and I are the co-directors and
that now that the press releases out in
the next few weeks will be sending
around a memo to all the faculty
explaining your the structure of the
project but what the key thing you
should think of if you're doing research
you think might fit into this in an
interesting way is that what we want to
do is different from the typical NSF
funding agency where you apply with a
proposal to some interesting idea that
might then go funded get funded and you
might go off and do it by yourself
publish a nice paper and get a best
paper award we're not interested in
specifically doing that kind of lone
ranger research what we're interested in
is using this as an opportunity to pull
together the most relevant most exciting
research that could fit into an
integrated collection of software that's
supported and hosted on this Yahoo
infrastructure so we can really build a
living
research environment on top of the Yahoo
infrastructure so if you're thinking
about how your research could fit in
think about it in those terms and then
come top adjusting the night maybe you
could talk a little about what your
dissipating we're actually going to be
so you're also going to see a memo from
Tom and I inviting students to opt into
this project and we've been talking
about sweetening the deal with some
mobile devices so we'll be inviting
people to be one of the users of this
new community what's so exciting about
this is and this has never happened
certainly to my knowledge we're going to
have access to everything on the yahoo
side that will allow our opt-in users to
have initially the current Yahoo
experience and then increasingly that
experience enhanced with replacement
software or brand new software and
hardware that we develop what's fabulous
about that for the user is it's exciting
you're part of a really fabulous
research project and you're going to
have an increasingly personalized
experience what's exciting about that
for us is that we have access to
thousands of instances of use of
everything we develop and so we can very
quickly iterate and turn around and send
back out into that situation improved
versions of everything we built
infrastructure and
a lot of variables or research and
thinkers who are going to be the project
we have a little bit more about the
breakdown of you know what are the
responsibilities to the opulent in
whatever
to start with as Justine just mentioned
we we need we haven't finished building
but we're in the process this
infrastructure that will allow people to
build new versions of our current
services on top of with their own ideas
or brand new services that we've never
considered before so one of our most
critical obligations sooner rather than
later if we can is to get that built and
get it shipped over here or at least
available to faculty and students here
at the University I think there in terms
of formal obligations there isn't a lot
written sort of in contractual language
that says we must do this you will do
this this is really a joint large-scale
research effort so a lot of its
unpredictable I guess our commitment on
both sides is to engage significantly
with each other and tackle really
interesting problems bring our best
people to bear so for our part we have
great scientists around the world it's
just just like Tom said earlier sort of
a call for people who and Justine could
have made it very clear in her sort of
portfolio of work gets you presented we
are looking for and I've already looked
for people whose work and interest are
very well aligned with this kind of
collaboration and we will be encouraging
people to come to Pittsburgh as
necessary offer internships to students
for the summer to come work with them
and be part of a larger effort together
but it's not it's not like a contract to
execute a certain system development
task together with milestones it's truly
an open-ended research project with kind
of a shared long-term vision and a lot
of excitement about the technology and
science that it would take to move
things forward and then we'll see where
it goes we have you know the obvious
things like planned regular meetings as
I mentioned earlier it's not like a
DARPA contract no go no goes or anything
like that so we'll take it one step at a
time and six months will evaluate where
we are it will change directions
investor Aric same thing in a year but
the I think the most important thing
as we've emphasized a few times is the
commitment to sort of this long-term
very substantial funding model that gets
out of the way that need to kind of
constantly go back and report on what
you're doing or ask for more money or
worry about whether your students will
see supported next year or the third
year of their graduate program so that's
that's clearly taken care of that is
contractually spelled out any other
thoughts to concrete examples of things
so 11 concrete illustration of how we
might interact is based on amber brown
skills were kind of know if Emma's in
the there she is so I'm not trying to
put you on the spot Emma but Emma does
is Justine pointed out a new talk some
really interesting work on bandit
problems exploitation exploration in
active learning of user preferences and
one of the early I won't say first
because I'm not trying to put him on the
spot but one of the earlier things that
we hope to see is Emma's research
extended and test it out in an app like
yahoo news for example and so that would
be a kind of very concrete example of
the kind of work that we'd like to do
but then when I give that example that's
one you know one faculty project with
her students working on this you can see
the direct relevance but more broadly
the second example I'd point out is if
you think about what Justine just
presented as a collection of research
and the five themes that she brought up
at the beginning of that you can see
that a key part of what we want to do
here is build models of the user both of
their preferences and their long-term
state and and demographics and so forth
but also their instantaneous state
Thomas currently sitting here speaking
it wouldn't be a good time during the
cell phone so
another second example would be we'd
like to pull together the many different
research projects that are currently
going on and integrate those into a
system that builds a single model and
takes advantage of an ins work and of
many other people's work so that instead
of having five different research
projects looking at different aspects of
user modeling here we really have an
opportunity to integrate those so that
each of those research projects can
leverage off the other features of user
that the other projects are learning so
that I wanted to bring up those two
examples just to try to ground it out
and to point out what really is the key
opportunity here it's synergy is the key
opportunity something that I've been
running on my desktop computer and
I like to use it but I can't wire all my
funds and would that be something if it
will work yea though I think that's
saying in different words exactly what
people were implying before that I think
this is a success of part of this will
depend on the number of people on campus
here who opted in to participate in this
potentially broad scale living
laboratory in some of our earlier DARPA
projects we had the same thing and with
enough users who have agreed you know my
data in this experimental setting is ok
to use everybody benefits but in fact
that's very much the idea here is that
largely from Carnegie Mellon there will
be experimentation with extensions or
novel services that can be built on top
of our infrastructure using current and
who knows what future mobile devices and
the whole idea is to try it in the real
world and see what happens and learn
through user experience what is pleasant
and usable what is distasteful or non
useful and make adjustments in real time
and I think again one of the most
exciting things about this for us and I
hope for our partners is the fact that
we're going to try to get everyone
access to the real stuff so instead of
in a classroom setting you get six
students over semester creating their
own mini version of yahoo fantasy
football or whatever which can happen
but you don't get the real thing you get
to use the real thing and so you don't
have to rebuild it you can move on to
the more experimental interesting stuff
and collect data from your own community
and start to understand what the use is
like so in some regards a major emphasis
of this is I hate this term but i'll use
it dogfooding we use it we use it at
yahoo now all the time I don't know what
ever happened to beta testing but in any
case indeed I think that's a major part
of this enterprise and hopefully it'll
provide a great venue for doing really
interesting research so we have time for
one last question
for scientists to suggest projects and
collaboratively to define projects then
the other thing is just to maybe tomm a
little more on the structure of what a
project is what the funding will be used
for including faculty summer salary all
designed to really promote the
collaboration active cooperation right
so it just to elaborate one point on Don
suggestion what is a typical funding
unit for example and what we're thinking
is that remember this is a gift gift
from yahoo not typical university over
headed research fund so we're thinking
on the order of a hundred thousand
dollars for a one-year unit of funding
to support a PhD student and a
substantial fraction of a faculty and
you know the numbers for so if you
multiply that by the usual overhead rate
that's like 170 k over 160 k + SF grant
but but in there the support for that
student makes that student a yahoo
fellow and we're hoping that through
awards of many of these will have a
whole community of yahoo fellows who and
will encourage both faculty and students
to take a trip out to yahoo sometime
during that year and really explaining
the research they're doing get to know
the research going on there so time for
one more question
working another line
I think in our discussions leading up to
finalizing the basic agreement we didn't
get specific about that yahoo of course
is present in a very large number of
countries and not everything we do is in
English in the labs we don't have a lot
of work going on right now around multi
lingual processes applications etc I
think it would be important for the
company we haven't given it much thought
I guess specifically in terms of what we
would do so if you have some ideas I
think the best thing is to propose them
and figure out how it might fit and then
we could see how things fit in but we
are an extremely international company
and so at least on the face of it that
consideration is really quite important
certainly to to us at Yahoo